[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire je reçois aujourd'hui marie
cann et pour son livre sur joséphine
baker
la première star noire de l'industrie du
spectacle
nico du groupe tagada jones qui sort un
album intitulé à feu et à sang et cédric
arles pour le livre rétro futur une
histoire des innovations énergétiques
que l'on a oublié qui pourrait nous être
utile aujourd'hui pour répondre aux
défis de la transition énergétique et
l'on commence tout de suite par ce qui
caractérise notre époque voici la
réponse de mes invités en images on
commence par la vôtre cédric de quoi
s'agit-il
c'est le sait une librairie qui est
installé sur le parvis de la gare de
saint-denis à paris donc c'est une
librairie qui installés dans un
container et luc pinto barreto se
définit comme un dealer de livres
l'idée c'est de voilà de donner un accès
à un endroit qui est pas forcément
équipés de librairie à une sélection de
livres et aya de la connaissance et est
à ce titre je trouve que dans notre
époque où justement on n'a pas trop
accès aux livres en ce moment où plus
trop ce projet est intéressant aussi
parce que parce que c'est un peu positif
est que dès que nous mêmes on travaille
en seine-saint-denis ont fait des
projets justement dans des containers on
donne aussi accès à la connaissance on
partage la connaissance et à ce titre
j'ai trouvé que c'était un très beau
projet à saluer pour amener un peu de
positivité danser dans ces périodes un
peu un peu un peu plombante sachant
aussi que la gare de saint-denis en tout
cas la place qui est devant réputé pour
ses commerces en tous genres et d'y voir
une librairie ça se tasse est assez
nouveau votre photo à vous nico le
chanteur et guitariste du groupe tagada
jones baiia du feu il n'y a pas de sens
mais il ya du feu et du feu bon c'est
vrai que c'est un rapport direct avec le
titre de l'album mais j'ai choisi cette
photo qui est une photo en fait d'un
d'un méga feux n'ont donc évidemment on
sait que depuis des années des années il
ya des incendies qui deviennent très
très difficile à contrôler et puis on a
passé une peut-être une certaine limite
son parti c'est méga feux avec des
incendies finalement qu'ils gagnent
quasiment incontrôlable c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui on arrivera encore j'irai
à aller à les contenir au bout de très
très longtemps mais pour moi ça
représente peut-être justement cette
limite qu'on est sûrement en train
d'atteindre en tout cas donc évidemment
je parle d'urgence écologique là quand
on parle de cheveux mais mais pour moi
ça représente aussi une espèce de
limites qu'on en attendant dans plein de
situations enfin il ya aussi cette idée
d'urgence économique cette idée de
d'urgence sanitaire actuelle et
l'impression voilà c'est on est
peut-être en train d'atteindre une
limite où la terre serait peut-être en
train de le reprendre ses droits
et enfin l'image de marie cann et de
joséphine baker et pas n'importe quel
jour voilà c'est ça c'est plutôt un
document disant historique qui date du
28 août 1963 et c'est le lincoln
memorial à washington et c'est la grande
marche pour les droits civiques ou
joséphine baker a été a pris la parole
en fait publiquement
elle est l'une des deux ailes et yack
deux femmes qui perdent à prennent la
parole ce jour là le jour où martin
luther king prononça son célèbre
discours j'ai fait un rêve est l'une des
deux c'est joséphine baker
on racontera tout à leur bas dans un
instant en fait on va raconter tout de
suite pourquoi
joséphine baker et bien commençons
[Musique]
alors marie cann et vous enseignez
l'esthétique à l'école des beaux-arts de
lyon et vous publiez baker aux éditions
françois bourin dans la collection icône
joséphine baker
c'est la première star noire je le
disais de l'industrie du spectacle
elle fait des débuts fracassants à paris
en 1925 elle a 19 ans d'abord comme
danseuse puis chanteuse et actrice
ça va être la première interprète noir
qui soit la vedette d'un film écrit pour
elle mais c'est aussi une autre preneuse
propriétaires de clubs très chic à
montmartre quelqu'un qui lancent des
produits dérivés à son nom comme la
brillantine baker fixe ou l'huile
bronzante baker hall
elle ouvrira même un parc d'attraction
dans son château et et en tant que
militante un anti-raciste com via le
voir comme on vient de le voir elle fera
un discours devant le lincoln memorial
juste avant lui martin luther king lors
de la marche de washington organisé par
le mouvement des droits civiques si l'on
y ajoute ses activités au service de la
france libre pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale on s'aperçoit à quel point
joséphine baker
c'est un personnage cardinal de
l'histoire du 20e siècle
oui et avant tout elle est très
agissante en fait à l'intérieur histoire
la modernité et dans le xxème siècle et
ce qui est intéressant c'est que quand
on lit en fait quand on s'intéresse à la
vie de joséphine baker
on s'aperçoit aussi que c'était alors
que c'était presque en fait elle arriva
en france dans les années 20 c'était il
ya un siècle
et quand on regarde un peu le mouvement
qui s'est opérée historiques culturelles
dans la société
on voit en fait que les questions
qu'elle pose est alors sont toujours
pertinentes aujourd'hui et ça c'est
assez troublant parce que c'est comme si
on avait bougé mais pas beaucoup
finalement en en un siècle et sa vie est
vraiment très très intéressante et
complexe puisqu'elle passe si long des
étapes elle même dans son processus dans
la manière dont elle va raconter sa vie
dans la manière où elle dans tes dents
qu'elle va s'inscrire dans la société
est vraiment elle produit comme ça des
virages qui sont esthétiques qui sont
culturelles qui sont politiques ils sont
aussi identitaire et et met en avant des
questions dont on débat en france dans
la presse aux etats unis aussi à
l'étranger
elle met en avant des questions qui
agitent en fait la société
alors commençons la question c'est
pourquoi est-ce que la première star
noire de l'industrie du spectacle
pourquoi n est-elle en france joséphine
baker arrive des états unis elle vient
de broadway en 1925 elle arrive pour
jouer dans la revue au théâtre des
champs elysées elle débarque du bateau
avec une troupe de jazz le spectacle est
refait immédiatement parce que c'est un
peu trop puritains pour les français
donc ça va devenir un peu plus olé olé
mais c'est très intéressant que ce soit
en france et pas ailleurs qu'elles
naissent en france où justement elle
incarne une forme de modernité c'est
très important à ce moment là c'est à la
fois la modernité du jazz du rythme
c'est un rythme totalement nouveau qui
va être le rythme du 20e siècle mais
aussi de l'avant garde artistique c'est
le cubisme aussi au même moment qui
règne et c'est une fascination pour
j'allais dire pour la négritude c'est
comme ça qu'on en veut qu'on l'appelle à
ce moment là oui c'est ça c'est elle
arrive en france en plein votre pote
est elle est vraiment une actrice
très dynamique de ce courant l'a en fait
je pense qu'elle renforce et en même
temps elle annonce aussi un peu la fin
de sa et le passage à autre chose parce
qu on est aussi dans l'europe
pré-fasciste donc en même temps il ya
d'autres considérations identitaires
qu'il traverse en fait là les débats
dans la société et en europe et
joséphine baker c'est vrai qu'elle
devient star en france un peu finalement
un peu par hasard un peu vain par hasard
plus tôt elle devient ce que les
populations élitiste éduquer parisienne
qui vont voir ce type de spectacle enfin
c'est à dire une pectives mans une icône
de la modernité
parce qu'elle est aussi américaine et
donc il ya aussi du jazz
et comme vous l'avez dit du cabaret
broadway et elle amène quelque chose je
crois qui est tout à fait nouveau en
france qui est d'abord une manière de
bouger son corps elle a une souplesse
incroyables et elle arrive à créer des
mouvements qui sont vraiment très jazz
et elle arrive à créer des enchaînements
qui n'ont jamais été vus en france et
notamment elle se sert de ses fesses
elle se sert de ses hanches de sa
poitrine alors que dans la france des
années 20 ce parti-là dans monde en tout
cas de du spectacle et de la
chorégraphie sont très peu utilisées
alors ça c'est pas ça qui explique
voilà aussi qu' elle devient comme ça
quelque chose de nouveau et puis elle
est aussi peut-être pour dans le monde
du spectacle et dans le monde de l'art
elle crée aussi une sorte d'ouverture si
vous voulez esthétique
c'est pour ça que certains voient dans
le phénomène de la vague des deux auquel
elle participe une occasion de
renouveler le champ des arts en france
et en même temps ce qui est formidable
c'est que à la fois et d'amen cette
envie si vous voulez à son apogée et l
annonce en même temps sa fin en passant
enel dans sa vie à autre chose joséphine
baker
aux etats unis c'est un personnage
comique qui qui louche c'est elle qui
arrive à à paris en 1925
mais quelques années plus tard c'est
l'autre celle qu'on voyait ramper sur le
sol magnifique à la fois sauvage entre
guillemets parce que c'est évidemment
tout un imaginaire colonial con qu'on
projette sur sur joséphine baker cet
imaginaire colonial on le sublime aussi
elle fascine la france entière joséphine
baker et c'est pas seulement sa nudité
parce que la nudité on y est habitué
elle va devenir la star des folies
bergères les femmes aux folies bergère
dans sa nue depuis depuis très très
longtemps on n'est pas à broadway on est
à paris
mais là tout à coup il ya un érotisme
très particulier qui est celui de
joséphine baker qui était comique
il ya deux trois ans qui devient
extrêmement érotique en très peu de
temps
oui et alors c'est vrai que je pense que
ça c'est un point très important le fait
qu'elles viennent du music hall et
surtout de la tradition du clown la
tradition du clown elle a vraiment quand
elle travaille aux états unis des rôles
de bray comique et dans la revue
qui est la revue qu'il a fait naître en
france il voulait en tant que joséphine
baker elle a aussi ce rôle de comique et
donc on l'a déjà dit pour qu'elles
puissent pour qu'elle puisse incarner
cet imaginaire colonial érotique un peu
sauvage un peu sulfureux un peu
dangereux et au fur et à mesure elle pas
se transformer elle même pour si vous
voulez coller à cette représentation
afin aussi de satisfaire cette audience
parisienne qui attend d'elle en fait ça
cet érotisme je veux dire exotiques
alors que joséphine baker finalement a
très peu à voir avec avec l'afrique est
en tout cas mais se trouve que les
aspirations colonial de la france des
années pains 30
ce projet s'il vous les dents sur le
corps de becker et à la vie répond avec
notamment cette danse qui va être très
célèbre où elle danse avec sa chute de
bananes et où en fait là le comique si
vous voulez ça sa technicité de clown
reprendre dessus où elle danse donc avec
sa jupe de bananes qui ressemblent à des
pénis lé fait bouger et elle elle louche
en même temps et ce qui est intéressant
c'est qu'en même temps elle louche et ce
qui veut dire qu'elle renvoie un reflet
à l'audience qu'il a regardé qui rigole
un reflet est en fait un miroir de leur
propre jugement de leurs propres
aspirations de leur propre critique et
le public rit de ça 2 la caricature
qu'elle qu'elle produit deux essais
mélange là avec baker sont toujours
intéressants parce que ce que j'ai
essayé de montrer c'est que c'est une
femme qui a une vraie science des médias
et qui a une vraie science du marketing
et l
comprends très bien en fait la place
qu'elle a sur scène et dans la société
et la manière dont à la fois elle peut
en tirer avantage
et la manière à la fois dont elle se des
identifiants en fait de cette aspiration
là et à l'intérieur entre ces deux
rencontres entre dans cet espace en fait
elle prend sa femme sa place par donc
vraiment comme tom créatrice alors il
faut voir elle est adulée un joséphine
baker en france c'est quand même
extraordinaire c'est la première fois
qu'une femme noire est adulé à ce point
là par le grand public par l'ensemble du
public
mais en particulier par l'avant garde
artistique elle va avoir une longue
histoire d'amour avec avec georges
simenon
elle va en avoir une autre plus courte
avec le corbusier
on va avoir en photo d'ailleurs sur le
paquebot ils se rencontrent pas debout
très chic ou et où ils sont tous
déguisés et son ascension est
extrêmement rapide
un moment vous montrer la photo de la de
la maison que adolphe alfred loulou ce
très grand architecte de l'époque va
dessiner pour elle ces pauvres qu'en
deux ans voilà les moyens qu'à joséphine
baker en deux ans elle peut se faire
construire ça elle ne le fera pas elle
va préférer s'acheter un manoir au
vésinet mais on lui des faits cette
maison alors que c'est pas hasard non
plus si elle est noire et blanche
cette maison mais c'est l'idée que l'on
se fait de joséphine baker à ce moment
là c'est une star immense qui a gagné
énormément d'argent
oui puis c'est une femme puissante est
là elle a une vraie place dans les
médias alors elle profite à la fois
c'est aussi ça qui est intéressant avec
baker parce qu'elle est déjà kitsch dans
un sens puis ce qu'on mange des
chocolats à son effigie puisque dans
chez les coiffeurs
il y a
partout en fait des publicités pour la
brillantine qu'elle a inventé et qui
s'appelle baker fixe mais keane
brillantine en fait assez classique un
acheté un brevet et elle a mis son nom
dessus
et donc c'est une femme puissante et
elle pas en fait cette puissance va un
peu si vous voulez je crois ce avec la
guerre va pas s'arrêter
et c'est là où en fait elle va changer
de rôle et elle m'a passé dans la
résistance
je veux dire elle va vraiment participer
elle va rallier l'appel du général de
gaulle quasiment quasiment site ou alors
il ya il ya des petits détails que vous
racontez dans votre livre qui sont
passionnants d'abord c'est une star
internationale très rapidement elle fait
une tournée dans toute l'europe mais
elle fait scandale dans toute l'europe
pas du tout comme en france à vienne en
allemagne par tous elle fait scandale
parce qu'elle est nu parce qu'elle est
noire parce qu'elle est la vedette
parce qu'elle représente paris avec tout
ce que ça peut avoir de sulfureux dans
le reste de l'europe pendant pendant les
années 20 elle pose en elle pose pour
vogue g n ya pas très longtemps parlé
qui elle a été la première mannequin
noir à faire la couverture de vogue mais
bien longtemps avant elle n'avait pas
fait la couverture mais elle était
photographiée par le grand photographe
de l'époque george hoenig est une en
veine histoire dans dans vogue elle
s'achète son manoir où elle s'entoure
d'animaux exotiques elle se promène avec
une une femelle guépard en laisse les
absolument extraordinaire elle est
chanteuse elle a beaucoup de succès mais
on fait des films pour elle autour
d'elle zouzou avec jean gabin princesse
tam tam avec albert préjean et à chaque
fois ça raconte l'histoire d'une femme
noire amoureuse d'un homme blanc est
l'homme blanc qui lui préfère une femme
blanche et ben oui et ça c'est
intéressant parce qu'elle était très
consciente de ça à la fois vraiment
l'ambiguïté c'est ça aussi j'ai essayé
de montrer dans mon texte c'est que à la
fois donc ces scénarios
elle participe complètement à l'écriture
donc elle est au courant de ce qui va
qui va de ce qui va se faire et elle
prend toujours pour ce rôle en fait
d'une femme qui vient d'un territoire
disons plutôt étrangers en tout cas qui
et racisées qui arrivent en france qui
va connaître une ascension qui va
trouver l'amour mais qui le réalisera
pas et c'est toujours avec des hommes
des hommes blancs et baker elle même
avait fait la remarque plus tard à
rebours
elle avait dit mais pourquoi par exemple
dans un film comme comme sousse ou
pourquoi je ne peux pas épouser
quelqu'un comme gabin est ce que c'est
parce que je suis noir et surtout dans
ce film là c'est s'est très c'est
ironique et c'est étrange parce que
finalement gamin lui préfère une fille
qui s'appelle claire et dans ce film
baker a un rôle de blanchisseuse voyez
il ya seize partants seuls vont lui tout
seul
et donc il ya ces il ya ces liens qui
sont qui sont étranges mais je pense
aussi qu'on ne peut pas non plus
comprendre cet humour si vous voulez ou
cette ironie
s'ils ont des tâches trop de de la
question du music hall ou dans le
music-hall la question de la caricature
est quelque chose de tout à fait de tout
à fait important et où baker d'ailleurs
dans certaines revues incarne une
personne grecque les puis devient
chinoise et puis donc il ya aussi ce
travail qui se passe au niveau du music
hall et je pense que si on oublie la
question de la caricature et de cette
espèce d'humour quoi qui fait que ça
marche
et quand baker d'ailleurs fait le clown
sur scène quand elle joue aussi c'est
vraiment aussi ce travail de la
caricature parce qu'elle vient de la
mefer même la caricature de sa propre
position au sein de la société
ça lui permet aussi de créer une
distance entre ce qui si vous voulez
l'identité qui lui est assignée est
celle que elle travaille en fait à la
fois dans le réel
dans ce qu'elle communique aux médias et
dans la fiction ce qu'elle incarne par
exemple sur celle où altran ce qui est
quand même de fascinant quand on lit
votre livre et qu'on s'intéresse à la
personnalité de joséphine baker et à la
france de l'époque
par la même occasion puisqu'elles sont
indissociables vous le montrer très bien
c'est que celle avance c'est à dire que
joséphine baker dans quand elle pose le
problème pourquoi je ne peux pas finir
le film en épousant le l'acteur blanc
elle pose la question composera à
hollywood cinquante ans plus tard au
moment de la sphère pélican quand denzel
washington partage la vedette avec julia
roberts et que à la fin il ne s'embrasse
pas ils s'embrassent pas parce qu'il est
noir et ça n'est pas dit comme ça mais
c'est ce que tout le monde comprend y
compris de nouvelles ou ashington on est
50 ans après zouzou de la même manière
quand on voit les rappeurs noirs lancer
leur ligne de t-shirts investir gagner
énormément d'argent avec leurs disques
et ensuite l'investir pour acquérir
cette indépendance économique qui leur a
toujours manqué aux etats unis ils le
font
longtemps après et joséphine baker
longtemps après qu'elle ait lancé ces
boîtes de nuit ou c ou c ou c
cosmétiques
bien sûr c'est pour ça que quand
j'essaie d'ouvrir aussi sur la question
alors bien sûr c'est j'aurais pu aller
plus loin parce que par exemple
joséphine baker est très important du
côté de la danse contemporaine est la
performance et j'avais publié j'avais
été directrice d'une édition enfin d'un
magazine qui s'appelle initiale qu'ont à
se consacrer la joséphine baker et à son
influence dans l'art contemporain mais
et dans le milieu de la performance mais
ce qui est intéressant effectivement moi
je parle que d'eux notamment de beyoncé
qui a fait un hommage très important à
joséphine baker en 2006 parce qu'en fait
joséphine baker on a un peu oublié cette
histoire surtout les jeunes générations
finalement quand on gratte un peu on
comprend que c'est la grand-mère de deux
beaucoup de choses aujourd'hui de
beaucoup de pratique et qui vaut pour
notamment pour pour les femmes ce que
j'explique donc mais c'est vrai que l a
inventé elle a participé si vous voulez
à tout le développement marketing et aux
innovations technologiques de la
modernité dont aujourd'hui on est
complètement héritier et quand je disais
que ce qui est étonnant en fait c'était
que de voir les questions avaient à
peine bouger
je trouve que ça dit beaucoup sur notre
époque je veux dire qu'en un siècle ou
dans 50 ans des questions fondamentales
sur l'inclusion ou sur les
discriminations soit toujours aussi
forte et toujours autant au coeur même
des productions culturelles fait que
comme un média hi hi hi
il ya des questions à se poser et c'est
un peu triste et en même temps c'est
chouette de voir qu'une femme dans les
années 30 a pu comme ça
remuer les choses avec autant
d'intensité et est aujourd'hui
effectivement beyoncé bon ce sont des
gens qui sont vos points reprennent les
mêmes l' usage des médias
moderne donc dans ses usages des coeurs
son côté très confidences très quand
elle met en fait sa vie en jeu à
l'intérieur des médias et qu'elle
travaille pour les médias et qu'elle
façonne sa gloire au travers d'une
histoire qui a décrit par les médias
elle est vraiment dans aujourd'hui
qu'ont constaté de plus presque banal et
ça quand même c'est intéressant voilà
que l epu avait elle ait pu aller jusque
là à l'époque alors il y avait cette
photo que vous aviez choisi quand on la
voit dans son uniforme des forces
aériennes
féminines de la france libre le jour de
son discours au lincoln memorial juste
avant martin luther king pourquoi
joséphine baker
c'est parce que elle va revenir
régulièrement les états unis après son
triomphe en france en europe en amérique
du sud
à chaque fois elle va se heurter aux
mêmes racisme américain il ya tout
d'incidents du store club que vous
raconter en détail où elle va se faire
dénoncer au fbi par walter rines seul
célèbre chroniqueur de l'époque comme
communiste carrément ils l'accusent
d'être communiste est aussi fasciste et
de ne pas aimer les noirs ce qui était
assez extraordinaire tout ça évidemment
c'est une
c'est une elle se bat pour l'égalité
raciale et c'est parce que je parlais de
son parc d'attraction dans lequel elle
va se ruiner c'est son fameux château de
2000 ans d'où elles élèvent les douze
enfants qu'elle a adoptés de 12 enfants
qu'elle a adoptés de toutes les couleurs
elle est allée les adoptés par tous
partout en europe partout elle veut en
amérique du sud partout où elle se
produisait elle les ramènent tous et
elle les montre en fait elle les montre
aux visiteurs du parc
et il ya une époque il y en a eu
beaucoup beaucoup de visiteurs elle veut
montrer une espèce de deux villages
antiraciste au fond oui c'est ce qu'elle
appelle le village mende
en fait son projet de famille parce que
c'est vraiment une mère aussi
mais son projet de famille c'est ce
qu'elle appelle la fraternité
universelle
après la guerre elle bondit j'allais là
là des difficultés comme tout le monde
pendant la guerre elle elle participe à
la résistance mais elle était très
malade
donc elle a surtout fait du deal
d'information pendant la guerre et après
la guerre par contre elle participe
activement aux alléchantes et si vous
voulez dans les bases militaires pour
réconforter comme le faisait marilyn
monroe comme le faisait beaucoup de
personnes à cette époque là si vous
voulez pour pour réchauffer pour le
moral des moral des troupes est là elle
va chanter dans des bases américaines et
elle est vraiment très choqué de voir
que on est juste après la guerre on est
là
libération en fait un et que soit elle
chante pour des blancs soit elle chante
pour des noirs mais que à l'intérieur d'
armée américaine en fait il ya toujours
des effets de ségrégation et là elle a
vraiment un choc et je pense qu'une
chose qui est pas évoqué mais j'imagine
on peut imaginer ce que ça l'était aussi
la découverte des camps après la guerre
et tout ça et donc elle arrive à un
niveau elle même par rapport à sa
sensibilité je crois d'intolérance par
rapport à ces choses là et elle rentre
là dans une vraie pratique d'activistes
anti raciste et elle tape sur l'amérique
de façon très publique
elle en parle dans les médias était
vraiment aucun cadeau et décale loi
qu'il ya un problème
elle collecte les informations elle crée
des rapports elle est vraiment très
active et elle en parle durant ces
conférences et comme elle est très
célèbre voilà elle profite de cette
puissance qu'elle a gagné avant la
guerre et l armée en jeu après la guerre
pour méditer pour pour les droits pour
les droits civiques et elle est une
pionnière parce qu'elle des avants en
fait les droits civiques elle est déjà
sûre sur ce terrain là votre livre
s'intitule baker marie cann et il est
paru aux éditions françois bourin dans
le dans la collection icône
[Musique]
nous voilà à présent avec nico vous êtes
le chanteur et le guitariste du groupe
de tagada jones qui s'est formé à rennes
en bretagne il y a dix sept ans et qui
sort son dixième album studio à feu et à
sang
alors le cinquième album s'appelait le
feu aux poudres
le septième s'était descente aux enfers
le neuvième vous l'aviez baptisé la
peste et le choléra à feu et à sang
c'est la suite logique en fait logique
27 ans qu'on joue on a 10 ans de plus ça
a pris dix ans de plus pardon on a
commencé en décembre 93
et oui c'est vrai que c'est la suite
logique de de tous ses albums évidemment
le petit album ça commence un petit peu
a raconté je pense que évidemment les
gens c'est à travers ces petites peuvent
vite comprendre qu'on est un groupe qui
a toujours été très engagé on a un
groupe indépendant en thaïlande
alternatif et on essayait de se battre
pour nos idées et du véhicule et ça à
travers nos nous nos concerts qu'on
donne un petit peu partout en france
même dans le monde puisqu'on a joué dans
32 pays différents on arrive bientôt à
2000 concernent avant tout quand même un
groupe de live et et c'est vrai qu'on a
beaucoup de messages à passer et je
crois qu'aujourd'hui c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça que j'ai choisi cette photo
teneur en cov est finalement aujourd'hui
le contexte a énormément changé je me
rappelle on a fait un morceau écolo il
ya plus de 20 ans et c'était pas très
peu de faire un morceau d'écolo c'était
un peu cédé presque la risée à cette
époque là et aujourd'hui je crois que
les plus jeunes c'est vrai que le groupe
rend compte beaucoup plus un plus gros
succès aujourd'hui notamment parce que
ya pas mal de jeunes qui se retrouvent
dans dans notre discours et dans tout ce
qu'on a pu
décrié depuis des années est en fait je
crois que ce qui change énormément c'est
le contexte pour ça que j'ai choisi
cette photo pour montrer que c'est
effectivement on arrive peut-être à une
limite que les jeunes voient venir et et
une limite en qui peut être présenté
aujourd'hui par cette urgence sanitaire
c'est cette urgence écologique tôt si
vous parlez dans votre dans une des
chansons qui s'appelle le dernier barils
dont on va regarder le clip
immédiatement même le regarder
on va même le regarder en entier waouh
cadets
d'or noir dans les terres
le marché
et fils il est venu
[Applaudissements]
de ma joie un talus de guillotine loeb
est sous les cordes est d'or sans pitié
une guerre sans fin jusqu'à ce qu'il
n'en reste plus qu'un
m
et
athènes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors on voit que c'est c'est pas très
optimiste on va être cherche très bon
album feel good music
vous êtes spécialiste mais on
al'impression alors évidemment quand on
voit ce clip ça rappelle mad max et on
le dit au fond mad max était pas très
écologiste mad max ils avaient peur de
la d'arriver au dernier baril parce que
ça les leurs en crise chez les empêcher
de conduire leur voiture ou leur grosse
moto vous est-ce que c'est pas ça aussi
derrière derrière celle ci non non
derrière tout ça évidemment on s'est un
petit peu ce qu'on veut démontrer c'est
et enfin on parle évidemment de cette
guerre qui se profile
évidemment à travers le la fin du
pétrole enfin on voit bien qu'on est
plutôt vers la fin avec eux bon on peut
aller beaucoup plus loin chez eux on a
eu des choses incroyables parmi notre
carrière dont on est allé jouer à dubaï
dans ses pas réservé qu'à ceux grosse
seconde français à dubaï mais c'est une
multitude de d'accumulation de choses
qui font qu'on s'est retrouvé là bas et
là bas ça a été incroyable
on prend des claques c'est la culture
c'est aussi voir des choses différentes
des choses auxquelles on devrait pas
être confrontés et c'est vrai qu'en
arrivant là bas on a discuté avec
beaucoup de français vous soyez il ya
beaucoup de français sur place et ils
nous ont tous dit mais là ce qui est en
train de se passer actuellement c'est
notamment tous les les les fondations
qui se crée donc la fondation des
émirats arabes unis venaient de se faire
juste derrière et à la fondation
d'arabie saoudite qui était en train de
se créer elles arrivaient directement
numéro deux et numéro 1 des fonds
d'investissements des investissements
dans le monde
parce qu'évidemment il voit tourner que
le pétrole aujourd'hui on est plutôt
proche de la fin du début et et voilà je
crois que le monde est en train de
changer il faut se restructurer
évidemment on parle de toutes ces
énergies renouvelables on sait pas trop
où on va non plus sur les énergies
renouvelables
donc là l'idée pour nous c'est plutôt 2
on va en parler avec avec l'invité
suivant mais je voudrais qu'on voit un
autre clip de un autre morceau tiré de
cet album qui s'intitule nous avons la
rage
le rock et la rage c'est un vieux couple
enfin reconstitué diront certains on
vous écoute et on vous regarde diffusée
dans les consciences américaine culte du
film l'amour de la défense dans la
violence par les armes illico plutôt que
les idées les actes les morts
see no more est very hot 100 m
face à ces inutiles toujours reese est
parfois évoquée ne prenez vous pas qu'on
fait n'est ce pas qui cachait
[Musique]
nicolas le rock et la rage je le disais
c'est un vieux couple jusqu'à ce que
l'europe devienne au fond la variété
internationale et la rage s'est retrouvé
chez les rappeurs c'est eux qui tout à
coup on chantait la rage que chantait
les rockeurs bien avant là vous y avez
ajouté la haine la haine c'est autre
chose
la haine elle était un peu chez les
punks mais c'était surtout la rage même
les punks c'était surtout la rage plus
que la haine
j'ai l'impression que c'est une
dimension nouvelle laine qui arrive
aujourd'hui dans l'europe qu'avec un
groupe comme le vôtre ouais alors je
pense que la saison c'est vraiment un
titre je peux pas dire que ce soit
généralisée et la haine c'est vraiment
moi comment j'ai ressenti ce morceau là
il posera il parle vraiment du goût ford
et gilet jaune et du poste gilet jaune
et est en fait le lounge là je la
ressens chez les gens donc pour moi
c'est vraiment à dissocier de la musique
du rock c'est plutôt l'état d'esprit des
gens qui sont descendus très nombreux
dans la rue pour défendre leurs
convictions et qui se sont fait bon
voilà le mouvement s'est fait gentiment
et tous et on va dire et nous le public
on est au contact de on est en contact
alors il faut aujourd'hui c'est vrai
qu'on peut être en contact via les
réseaux sociaux ce qui est un monde
aujourd'hui virtuel et tu peux plus dire
grand chose j'ai l'impression où les
gens s'invente une nouvelle vie et puis
il ya un gain les lèveraient endroit où
les gens se retrouvent et les concerts
bompas actuellement malheureusement mais
les concerts c'est quand même un lieu où
on parle réellement avec les gens et moi
je prends toujours un temps important
pour discuter avec les gens et j'ai
vraiment alors c'est vrai comme on est
dans un mou de revendicatif on croise
beaucoup de gens qui ont été extrêmement
déçu par le las la finalité de ce
mouvement et pour la première fois voilà
j'avais vraiment l'impression que la
rage est en train de se transformer en
haine et d'ailleurs je crois
qu'aujourd'hui il ya il ya beaucoup de
gens qui sont chez eux toujours en train
de bouillir et qui ont font d'eux cette
haine qui sait qu'il s'est créé donc
c'est vrai que je parle pas vraiment dû
du rock et de l'industrie du rock de la
musique je parle plutôt du ressenti du
du peuple à feu et à sang c'est le titre
du nouvel album de tagada jones et pour
les conserves là il faudra attendre
malheureusement encore un petit peu
[Musique]
cd karl vous vous êtes designer
chercheurs fondateur d'ateliers 21 et
vous publiez rétro futur avec thomas
ortiz et eric du cerf chez buchet
chastel avec une préface de bertrand
piccard qui était d'ailleurs dans cette
émission il y a quelques semaines c'est
une contre histoire d innovation
énergétique vous êtes intéressé en fait
aux brevets d'autrefois souvent oublié
que l'on pourrait utiliser aujourd'hui
pour répondre aux défis de la transition
énergétique et il y en a plein et ils
sont extraordinaires quand on lit votre
livre on est sidéré qu'on a qu'on ait
inventé déjà tout ça bien avant
aujourd'hui c'est ça on est nous mêmes
sidéré des choses qu'on reçoit parce que
c'est un projet en constante évolution
qui a commencé sur internet d'ailleurs à
base de réseaux sociaux et à base d'une
frise chronologique qui s'appelle le
palio palais au tir et énergétiques
point org et on reçoit des inventions
chat quasiment chaque semaine en fait
aujourd'hui le site web est aussi
traduit en arabe en japonais en allemand
en espagnol on espère en russe bientôt
pourquoi pas ce qu'on va chercher dans
des inventions dans différents
territoires linguistique puisque les
crises successives ces 200 dernières
années ont mené en fait des groupes
sociaux à se débrouiller autrement
qu'avec le pétrole qu avec de
l'électricité ou ou des fois dans
certaines glisse le même le bois devient
très cher et donc il ya eu plein
d'innovations qui ont qui ont qui ont
qui ont été créés aussi des innovations
sociales et qui sont retombés qui se
sont dégonflés quand le prix du terrain
du pétrole et du baril est revenu en
fait à adhérer à des prix normaux qui a
une accessibilité de nouvelles du gaz et
du pétrole d'un seul coup toutes ces
inventions disparaissent aujourd'hui on
fait face à l'enjeu climatique est un
enjeu de de ressources on a on atteint
des limites
donc on sait on a trouvé que c'était une
bonne idée d'aller chercher dans le
passé de rétropédaler et d'aller
chercher surtout des choses qui sont
dans le domaine public et donc on peut
mettre en open source pour accélérer la
transition de manière globale et
décentralisé alors par exemple premier
exemple y en a plusieurs liées à
l'industrie
enfin l'énergie solaire par exemple la
première c'est l'imprimante solaire de
de mouches et en 1882
on va on va l'avoir puisqu'à chaque fois
en plus vous nous montrer les images de
l'époque là c'était une revue pour les
enfants qui nous raconte l imprimante
solaire de mouches et en deux mots parce
qu'on va regarder plusieurs mais c'était
quoi l'imprimante solaire de mouches et
en quoi ça peut nous être encore utile
aujourd'hui
alors cet inventeur à l'époque en fait
ils révolutionnent la concentration
solaire donc c'est la manière de
concentrer en fait les rayons solaires
il fait du coup fonctionner des machines
à vapeur
nous on pense qu'il s'est inspiré de
léonard de vinci qui voulait faire ça
avant lui
léonard de vinci qui a fini sa vie en
touraine augustin mouche ok donc
tourangeaux eux aussi à l'époque et
enseignant en mathématiques
je pense mais le nez en fait dans les
écrits de vinci et retrouve de la
concentration solaire puisque 20 si vous
voulez faire fondre du bronze à
l'énergie solaire et et voilà quasiment
qu'à 400 ans après va réactualiser ça il
va devenir un des pionniers de l'énergie
solaire à concentration puisque
effectivement c'est le premier à faire
ça en 1881 et ils feront d'ailleurs dans
paris fonctionner une imprimante
donc ils vont imprimer des journaux le
soleil journal qu on recherche toujours
d'ailleurs parce que notre métier où
j'ai envie de dire à travers ce projet
c'est aussi de recueillir des fonds
d'archivés d'aller chercher des pièces
moi même je suis je suis collectionneur
de pièces énergétique et donc on ne
désespère pas de retrouver les journaux
qui ont été imprimés à l'époque et et
qu'on aimerait bien lire puisque je
serai bien que de savoir ce qu'ils
racontaient est déjà à l'époque il y
avait aussi une coalition avec zola avec
toute insulte d'ailleurs le parisien
vous vous faites allusion dans votre
livre à un roman de d'emile zola
s'appelle travail est justement qu ils
s'aspergent qui s'inspire de mouches au
c'est ça je pense qu'à l'époque on
zola et un certain nombre
d'intellectuels ont compris qu'il y
avait des limites à exploiter le charbon
des limites sanitaire des limites
sociales des limites humaniste en fait à
utiliser ces énergies non renouvelables
et puis il ya toute une vague de
d'inventeurs qui travaille justement à
sur les énergies renouvelables et emile
zola va sortir son dernier ouvrage qui
est très méconnue qui s'appelle travail
où il va écrire il valait dedans il va
parler d'énergie solaire donc pour pour
se débarrasser du charbon et il va
parler notamment de on né en 1901 il
parle de véhicules électriques en
autopartage
donc on a géré est exhumé là aussi une
vision n'est pas tellement de la science
fiction parce que zola en fait c'est un
immense enquêteurs de la société et
voilà à travers ce dernier ouvrage en
fait il va livrer une sorte de vision
comme ça énergétique pour ceux se disant
prêt très non pas du pétrole à l'époque
mais du charbon est là l'image que l'on
voit c'est le film qui en a été tiré en
ça serait travail comme le roman d'emile
zola
vous faites allusion également dans
votre livre elle est ni l énergie
solaire en afrique
elle a une histoire en afrique par
exemple vous citez abdou moumouni dans
les années 70 80
il ya des innovations génial en termes
d'énergie solaire en afrique à ce moment
là absolument on a on a un des
chercheurs qui est basé à lyon qui
s'appelle frédéric caille avec qui on
travaille très étroitement qui lui est
spécialiste de l'histoire de l'énergie
solaire en afrique et qui a exhumé
notamment des des pépites puisqu'il a il
a redécouvert abdou moumouni la re
découvert aussi la sofres qui est une
société française qui a été créée dans
les années 60 par jean-pierre girardier
et qui faisait des pompes solaires
thermodynamiques notamment au sénégal
mais aussi au niger et qu'ils étaient
bien en avance sur son époque c'était
vraiment de la grande innovation
on a d'ailleurs réussi j'irai un peu au
forceps à faire rentrer une maquette de
ses pompes solaires thermodynamiques qui
sont une innovation mondiale à l'époque
au conservatoire national du
des arts et métiers de paris puisque
voilà en fait en termes d'énergies
renouvelables ya quasiment rien dans ce
musée et c'est bien pour ça qu'on
souhaite créer le rétro futur museum
puisqu'on à nous mêmes une collection
est un fonds très intéressant qu'on
souhaite exposer à paris dans en 2021 en
tout cas voilà on va créer un petit
musée parce que tout ça il faut qu'on
puisse le mettre à disposition de
désintéresser des gens qui veulent faire
la transition énergétique
voilà ça c'est sûr les les images en
afrique qu'on retrouve dans votre livre
mais on trouve aussi des images qui
peuvent paraître totalement saugrenu
aujourd'hui les panneaux solaires de la
maison blanche c'était sous jimmy carter
quand tu me carter et président des
états unis de 1976 à 80 il met des
panneaux solaires à la maison blanche
s'ils seront tous démantelé par ronald
reagan qui lui succède en 1981 c'est ça
je trouve que c'est intéressant parce
que ça fait un petit clin d'oeil à la
politique de trump qui est sortie des
accords de paris et que voilà joe biden
en fait tu souhaites de remettre sur la
table en fait aussi avec un plan sur les
énergies renouvelables
voilà en fait on voit que carter dans
les années 70 ça à cause des crises du
pétrole et deux enfin on voit le bazar
que sahamies en fait le prix du baril
explose
il ya il ya plus de pétrole etc la
france les états unis lancent des
programmes de recherche sur les énergies
renouvelables à tout va et puis le jour
où le prix du baril l'ird et s'en va
tout le monde oublie tout ce qui a été
fait et on vire les panneaux solaires
qui était sur la maison blanche
et c est en france c'est pareil on a
oublié tout un programme de recherche
qui était qui était pionnier en fait
qu'ils étaient bien en avance sur
l'éolien sur le solaire voilà bah parce
que en fait le baril et pas cher donc
c'est plus la peine de se faire on est
surtout misé à l'époque sur le tout
nucléaire
c'est à partir de 2009 74 pierre messmer
qui fait le choix du tout nucléaire pour
répondre justement elle est la crise du
pétrole de l'époque et au prix du baril
qui avait considérablement augmenté
passant que tu as dessus japonais c'est
un système de chauffage près du corps
alors qu'il ya ça sent il ya cinq
siècles que les japonais utilisent ce
système de chauffage et ses revenus dans
les années 70
demain au japon et puis aussi depuis
fukushima
alors le kotatsu c'est effectivement une
tradition japonaise que les japonais
estiment que chauffer des grands espaces
en tout cas les volumes de la maison
c'est un déchet en fait c'est un déchet
énergétique et du cou du coup ils ont
cette grande tradition de chauffer près
du corps et le kotatsu effectivement
tout comme les techniques anciennes dans
l'habitat ancien en europe aussi
consistait à chauffer proche du corps et
celle ci est particulièrement
intéressante puisque en fait on a des
tables qui sont chauffés par en dessous
et qui permet de confiner si je peux
m'exprimer ainsi en fait une sorte de
chauffage comme ça autour du corps c'est
ce qu'ont aujourd'hui le chauffage et
sousse et sous la couverture qui repose
sur la table qu'il est qui sépare les
deux femmes
voilà et aujourd'hui on est en train
devrait interpréter ça on a mené des
ateliers avec les couturières masqué de
deux tours la semaine dernière on a
refait des quotas dessous moderne pour
pour habiller leurs tables de travail
parce qu'elles ont des locaux qui sont
pas chauffées malheureusement et donc à
force de travail et des heures dans des
locaux qui sont pas chauffées c'est
assez inconfortable et donc on a créé
avec elle en récupérant des couvertures
en laine
on a recréé en fait un système de quotas
dessous avec un petit chauffage en
dessous en fait elles ont du coup un
confort thermique absolument absolument
fantastique on fait ça aussi avec des
étudiants en fait l'idée c'est de
réhabiliter en fait certaines idées et
de les rendre de les rendre moderne
d'ajouter des fois des briques
technologiques et pouvoir réhabiliter
voilà tout c'est toute cette boîte de
pandore en fait autre exemple les piles
alcalines rechargeable de carl cordes de
rech
ça c'était en 1981 c'est devenu la red
box d'ateliers 21 en fait raconté
douceur de mauvais ça c'est ça on en a
on a réussi à retrouver un brevet qui
permet de recharger les piles non
rechargeables donc les piles alcalines
donc autant vous dire que quand on est
tombé là dessus on a trouvé ça assez
hallucinant en se documentant un petit
peu on a découvert que c'était car le
cordage qui est aussi un monsieur qui a
travaillé à l'époque les piles de la
mission apollo donc on s'est dit bon
c'est un grand chercheur ça a l'air ça
n'a pas l'air d'être une fake news et on
s'est dit on va quand même vérifier
effectivement les piles alcalines à
usage unique dit non rechargeables sont
rechargeables
donc on dit pour ne pas confondre
indications régénéra blé donc on a
inventé régine boxe on a tout simplement
repris ce brevet en fait dans le domaine
public dont la réactualiser on est en
train de démontrer que non seulement on
peut régénérer ses piles mais que
économiques insee rentable que en
afrique et aussi beaucoup de gens qui
sont intéressés
ici il ya des entreprises qui sont
intéressés des maisons de quartier des
écoles des collégiens des collégiennes
qui quitterie des piles qu'il et
régénère et mêmes sans parler de
régénération on a aujourd'hui je crois à
peu près deux piles sur cinq qui sont
jetés en france qui sont quasiment
neuves et donc on peut réutiliser les
gens sans le savoir jette des piles qui
sont qui sont neuf à parce que on n'a
pas chacun à votre fenêtre on sait pas
ce que c'est un box etc et donc on est
en train de d'imaginer aussi des robots
trieur de piles et des choses qui
pourraient permettre de mieux gérer ses
33 mille tonnes de déchets par année
rien qu'en france qui sont source d'une
démence pollution aux métaux lourds et
et que et que voilà notre communauté a
permet d'endiguer et de travailler
collectivement sur ce sujet s'est dit
carl quand on lit rétro futur on se dit
mme c'est fou tout ce qu'on a oublié par
exemple on parle beaucoup de voitures
électriques depuis quelques années on
parle même d'une porsche électrique on
se dira ce serait quand même drôle d'en
arriver là une porsche électrique
ben quand on lit votre livre on
s'aperçoit que la première porsche elle
était électrique
d'ailleurs la voilà et c'était une
voiture 100% électrique
c'est ça absolument elle avait on voit
les d'ailleurs les moteurs alternateurs
dans les roues c'est à dire qu'elle
recharge et même les batteries en fait
au freinage
on a un autre exemple c'est la voiture
de thomas edison electric un prix de
1000 miles donc ses 1600 km à l'époque
donc on voit et c'est intéressant c'est
une voiture qui est plutôt légère et
puis c'est une technologie nickel fer
est donc à ce titre ne serait ce que
pour les ingénieurs d'aujourd'hui qui
réfléchissent à la transition
énergétique
je pense aux ingénieurs engagé un clic
un grand mouvement de jeunes français
ingénieur qui souhaitent voilà
travailler sur ces questions là bas en
fait on leur dit allez-y regarder les
batteries nickel fer de l'époque les
brevets sont dans le domaine public vous
pouvez les reprendre on peut rajouter
peut-être des briques technologiques
étaient manquantes et arriver à des
choses qui sont intéressantes et c'est
vraiment le but de ce projet c'est de
montrer que qu'il ya beaucoup de choses
à faire dans ce qu'on a déjà et il n'y a
pas besoin de réinventer des nouvelles
technologies et puis elle le retrofit
inga qui consiste à transformer les
véhicules existants il ya deux exemples
dans votre livre il ya là deux chevaux
électrique à hélices de monsieur leroy
en 1900 c'est quoi c'est dans les années
70 je crois et puis la voiture à
hydrogène de jean-luc perrier on va les
regarder toutes les deux la série las de
la deux chevaux à hélice qu'est ce qu'il
a à dire sur celle ci alors il faut que
je il faut que je dise que l'idée de
l'hélice n'est pas une bonne idée parce
que tout énergéticiens c'est qu'on va
pas récupérer beaucoup d'énergie en fait
part par par cette hélice par contre ce
qui est intéressant c'est le fait que
c'est un pépé à la retraite qui fabrique
ça tout seul dans son coin et donc on
n'a pas besoin de grosses r&d pour faire
ça et puis l'exemple de douala du
rétrofit c'est important parce que on
parle de sauver le climat aujourd'hui
ok et donc on nous propose des véhicules
hyper technologie c'est avec des
batteries qui sont fabriqués à l'autre
bout du monde
moi j'ai envie de dire le retrofit ça
fonctionne très bien
on peut aussi retrofit et à l'hydrogène
des véhicules c'est ce que faisait à
jean-luc perrier avec sa simca 1000 à
l'époque lui même il fabriquait
l'hydrogène avec de l'énergie solaire et
la finance et ça lui même
j'ai envie de dire en plus on parle de
los teques aujourd'hui on parle de
résidence des territoires etc
donc c'est pas juste une question
d'efficacité énergétique la transition
énergétique et écologique et la
résilience c'est aussi une question de
capacité du savoir distribuer sur des
territoires et donc même si on a des
rendements qui sont un peu moins bons
avec l'hydrogène dans un moteur
thermique
c'est des solutions qu'il faut envisager
c'est des choses qu'il faut mettre sur
la table parce que sinon on saute pas
climat
sinon on fabrique plus on crée des
impacts qui sont à l'autre bout du monde
et ça rime à rien il ya un truc qu'il
faut que je qu'il faut que je vous dise
et sait à quel point aussi la polémique
qui assure les véhicules électriques
aujourd'hui elle est un petit peu
faussée c'est à dire qu'on prend les
plus mauvais exemple et puis on en fait
une généralité
il ya un docu suisse qui est sorti il ya
pas longtemps qu'ils s'appellent à
contresens qui est vraiment très
intéressant parce que les sept équipes
de le pfl est allé enquêter un peu sûr
sûr sûr tout ce qu'on raconte sur les
véhicules électriques les batteries etc
et puis il ya il n'y a pas tous qui a
jeté en fait typiquement dans la dans la
zone de chez renault il ya pas de
terreur etc
par contre vous prenez la tesla et
certaines grosses voitures allemandes
électrique
il ya des terres rares dedans et donc
qui est donc la voiture électrique
normalement si c'est réellement moins
d'impact après ça dépend comment la
fabrique
ça dépend quelle énergie avec quelle
énergie on recharge la voiture etc mais
c'est des moyens qui sont hyper
intéressant il perd économes en énergie
hyper efficace et donc il faut pas tout
jeter de la voiture électrique il faut
bien la pensée et surtout il faut faire
du rétrofit parce que effectivement
c'est de l'emploi délocaliser c'est
faire travailler les
les garagistes français 44 me de garage
en france on va pas tous les mettre à la
pile à combustible du jour au lendemain
ça c'est pas vrai c'est faux on va pas
tous les mettre à l'hydrogène le
lendemain mais par contre on peut leur
faire faire du rétrofit électrique on
peut leur faire évoluer les véhicules et
ça c'est moi n'a pas que tu essaies de
la création d'emplois indélocalisables
donc ça me paraît quand même respecter
toutes les toutes les tous les drapeaux
politique qu'on agite en disant il faut
du local il faut de la transition
énergétique il faut créer de l'emploi et
il faut minimiser les impacts et donc je
comprends pas que ça ne pénètre pas
laissé faire et que on s'en empare pas
parce que les technologies sont là il ya
juste à claquer des doigts pour pouvoir
pour avancer sur cette transition la
rétro futur ça vient de paraître chez
buchet chastel un livre absolument
passionnant merci cédric kahn merci tous
les trois d'avoir participé à cette
émission on merci de nous avoir suivis
et rendez vous comme d'habitude au
prochain numéro
[Musique]